[MUSIC]
The first memories I have as a kid
are the cozy Italian Sundays with
my mom at the movie theater.
My favorite movie of them
all was Disney Fantasia.
I watched lazy Mickey Mouse
trying to teach that broom how to
clean the sorcerer's cave.
And I thought to myself how incredible
it would be if all things around me
could simply come to life.
If I could teach them to do all
the things I didn't want to do,
including, guess what, tidying my room.
Mickey Mouse's strategies seem
to be working out pretty well.
The broom started cleaning the cave
autonomously, and so happy and
relieved, Mickey simply went to sleep.
There was really nothing to worry about.
But a few hours later,
he wakes up to a completely flooded cave.
The brooms had been repeating
the same action over and
over again without realizing
what was going on around them.
So Mickey begged them to stop,
but they just won't listen.
And so
all he could do was tear them apart.
Unfortunately, a few hours later,
Mickey quickly realizes it's too late,
he has lost control.
This time more and
more brooms start invading the cave again,
desperately, trying to make it more clean.
Fast forward, many years, I find
myself often going back to the story,
as I try to think about the role of
artificial intelligence in our society.
These intelligent algorithms promised
to bring speed, efficiency, and
effectiveness, but ended up making
crucial decisions on our everyday lives.
Who gets better education,
better health care,
better financial support,
and who goes to jail.
But just like we don't expect that broom
to understand what we mean by clean,
it's up to us to decide and
teach those algorithms what we mean
by right, by fair, and by good.
The thousands of decisions of
this kind are made every day
by data scientists around the world.
What data to use,
what to optimize for, and
when a machine learning
model is accurate enough.
Well, I am a data scientist, and
let me tell you one thing,
you should not trust me.
And you should not leave it to
corporations, governments, or
researchers to make these decisions for
you.
And not because they intend harm, but
because this is not a technology problem,
this is a values problem.
And I believe all of us should have
a say in the role of AI in our society.
And let me show you why.
In February 2019,
Nijeer Parks was arrested.
He was accused of shoplifting and
trying to hit a police officer.
Turns out his face was identified
using a facial recognition software.
But after ten days in jail,
the police found out that was a mistake.
In August 2020, Shapiro is one
of thousands British students
who saw their college admissions revoked.
The UK government had just started
using a new AI tool instead
of final exams that was penalizing
struggling schools in poor areas as
opposed to elite schools in wealthy areas.
Today, Compass is one of the most widely
used AI tools in US criminal justice.
So what Compass does is it helps judges
determine whether a defendant should be
kept in jail or not while awaiting trial.
And it does so by associating a score
from 1 to 10 to each defendant,
based on more than 100 personal factors.
If this score is high enough,
that defendant will be jailed.
But analyzing the behavior of this
algorithm showed that bias data
coming in produced bias results going out.
Let's take Vernon and Brisha, for example.
Brisha committed minor prior offenses and
no subsequent offense,
yet as you can see her risk score
is much higher than Vernon's.
So what does fair mean to us,
in this case?
Does it mean we want to apply
the same criteria to both of them?
Or does it mean ensuring that
they're both equally likely to be
subjected to algorithmic error?
Because these two definitions
are equally valid but
they have a very different
impact on society as a whole.
So you see why deciding on rules and
values it's so hard,
because they mean different things for
every one of us.
Okay, I know what you're thinking.
Isn't that why we elect our decision
makers to make these complex decisions for
all of us?
Well, in theory, that's true, but
the problem with that is democracy
is not doing that well these days.
In the past few years as a youth activist,
I have worked hard with
the objective of involving as many
young citizens as possible in
the democratic lives of their communities.
And I could see how democracies
are continuing to weaken,
institutions appear distant,
self-protective, unreliable.
Only one in three Americans
trust their elected officials.
The political class struggles to
understand the complexity of technology
and to find consensus on the most
divisive matters of our time.
We used to think that democracy happens
once every four years in a ballot, but
it doesn't have to be this way.
Researchers and activists have studied
a new model of engagement in the past
few decades, deliberative democracy.
And to see what that means,
let me take you back to Ireland 2015.
80% of the Irish people approve
gay marriage in a referendum.
But that journey started
two years earlier when
the Irish parliament was facing
a controversial issue for
Ireland's history, and
decided it was time to try something new.
So they called a convention
on the constitution,
composed of 66 ordinary citizens and
33 members of their parliament.
They came together, debated,
discussed, and some of those
recommendations were then turned into
referendums that became reality.
So what happened here?
While the world thought these
citizens were just too polarized,
distant, and
frankly incompetent to have an impact,
they actually transitioned from
observers to decision makers.
And you can see and you can hear how
the narrative changed from they,
the policy makers, to we, the citizens.
Just like many activists around the world
that are doing already, we can influence
the political agenda by becoming good
lobbyists for the causes we believe in.
Deliberative democracy can happen
in many forms, citizens assemblies,
town halls, participatory budgeting.
And it has happened everywhere in the
world, from British Columbia to Karala,
from Brazil to Denmark,
from Oregon to Belgium.
In Italy, is trying to activate
the debate on climate change.
And in California,
citizen's assemblies were proposed to
solve the problem of homelessness.
I guess what you're thinking,
this woman is trying to disrupt our
institutions as we know them for
a new utopic, direct democracy.
Couldn't be more wrong.
I am suggesting we empower these
institutions every day with
active citizenry.
So how can deliberative democracy really
help us design the role of AI in our
society?
Well, first of all,
we'd have to define and
select a sample of citizens that can
be representative of our diversity.
And then we need to set up the process,
involve experts,
secure our decision makers commitment, and
decide the questions we want to tackle.
Because if we want to design a new bill
of digital rights, we'll have to agree
on things like fairness, transparency,
openness, explainability.
We'll have to decide how data
is transferred and owned.
We'll have to decide who audits,
who controls who.
It will not be an easy process, it will
require patience, experimentation, and
trust in the process, even and most of
all, when we don't agree with the outcome.
But ultimately, it'll help us understand
that beyond labels, we are simply humans.
I am very, very passionate about AI.
I really believe it can be an incredible
source of good for the world.
Could AI be the next decision maker?
Could AI find the best taxation
policy to optimize social welfare?
Or could we just leave it to
AI to solve climate change?
Maybe, we just don't know yet.
But if and when AI will be
able to find those answers,
we'll need to ask the right questions.
And when AI will be able
to find the best solutions,
we will need to agree on
what we mean by best.
All of us should have a say in
the role of AI in our society.
Now I don't know how many of you
have seen Disney Fantasia, but
here's a little spoiler for you.
In the end, the sorcerer comes in and
saves the day.
But the role of AI in our
society is no Mickey Mouse game.
So please stay active, stay informed,
participate in your democracy,
give it one more chance.
Because this time there will be
no sorcerer coming to save us.
This time we cannot afford to go to sleep.
This time we can and
we must write the rules together.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]